>> From the library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good
afternoon, I'm Georgette Dorn.
I'm the Chief of the Hispanic
Division of the Library of Congress.
And I'm so pleased to
see so many people here
on such a terrible,
rainy and dark day.
So, welcome, welcome
to Hispanic month.
I just wanted to tell you how
pleased I am to be talking to people
who have never been here before,
because I don't know your faces.
So, you must be from
Georgetown University, I assume?
No? Well, it's great to have you.
We do have the most wonderful
Hispanic collection anywhere
in the world.
Because we have books not only
published in Latin America,
but also books about Latin
America, published in China, Japan,
Germany, all over the world.
So, for that reason, our
secondary book collection
and newspaper collection is,
there is no rival in the world.
In addition, we have lots of
microfilms, newspapers, manuscripts,
printed photographs, and we have
about 8 million maps and atlases.
So, if you can find time,
please use our collection.
It's a great pleasure now
to introduce Christina Arce,
who is one of our users
of our collections.
She's a professor of Spanish
and Latin American literature,
18 to 19 century, at the
University of Miami in Coral Gables.
She's a graduate of the University
of California at Berkeley,
PhD and a Masters from Middlebury
College, and undergrad degree
from Santa Barbara, California.
And she's the author of this
wonderful book, "Mexico Nobodies."
Which is going to be
on sale outside.
So, with that, Christina Arce.
[ Applause ]
>> Christina Arce: Wow, I guess I'd
like to know where everyone is from.
Because if Georgette, Ms. Dorn
doesn't know you, I'd like to know
where you hailed from on a rainy,
miserable day such as today.
The university?
I feel like maybe there's
a class here?
Really, just interest.
Wow. Well, this is
fantastic thank you so much.
And I'd like to thank
everybody for coming today.
This is such a pleasure.
And in particular Dr. Anna
Dini [assumed spelling]
and Katalina Gomez [assumed
spelling] for their initiative
in organizing today's event.
And especially to Georgette Dorn,
the Chief of the Hispanic Division
for graciously supporting this event
as part of Hispanic Heritage Month
at the Library of Congress.
It's an honor for me to present
this book in this prestigious place
of learning that's dedicated to
the preservation of knowledge.
Eight million maps.
That's incredible.
I'm beholden to my colleagues
for engaging with my work.
Please have a seat.
Have a seat.
There's seats.
And I think it's especially a
apropos, given that my book grapples
with the invisiblized
histories of women in Mexico.
So, I thought I would
tell you a little bit
about how I began this
project many, many years ago.
I was a first-year's master
student, political science,
and I took a course on
Mexican history just for fun.
As a Mexican-American, I wanted
to know a little bit more
about Mexican history.
And in the textbook,
that was assigned to us,
there was three-quarters of a
page dedicated to the soldadera,
the female camp followers
of the Mexican Revolution.
Intrigued, I searched
for more information
and when I asked my
father who they were.
He responded that they were
the wives of the soldiers.
And soon I realized that this
was a euphemistic way to refer
to the women who appeared in all the
films I had watched with my family
on Sunday afternoons on one
of the few Spanish channels
in Los Angeles at the time.
This led me to consider who
were these women, these wives.
Can you hear me?
Okay. And why were they in
all the photographs and films
of the Mexican Revolution, when not
even a page on them was included
in an historical primer
of over 500 pages.
So, in the course of this informal
research on these women warriors,
I happened upon the only
novel dedicated entirely
to a female camp follower turned
colonel, Le Negra Angustias.
And like most Mexicans at the time.
I too was unfamiliar
with the importance
of Afro descendants
to Mexican culture.
And I found it striking that an
award-winning novel could be written
about a black female [foreign word],
when Afro Mexicans are not
considered a relevant part
of Mexican culture, if at all.
These paradoxes whereby the cultural
imaginary is saturated with images
of anonymous camp followers in
everything from photography, film,
art, and popular balladry;
including songs as popular as,
you perhaps know them, "La
Cucarracha" and "La Adelita."
Yet, the real women in official
history are unknown is what inspired
this book.
Thus, I explore how
individual people come
to embody larger conceptual
metaphors in Mexican history.
Such as how, for example, the
soldadera, as an occupation,
came to represent the
overwhelming cultural panic provoked
by women bursting out of the
home and into the public sphere.
And considered the role
that the arts played
in understanding these people
and their contributions
to Mexican culture and history.
So, I'm going to start by
reflecting on the cover of the book.
This photograph is of an
Afro Mexican [foreign word].
Originally thought to be a
soldadera, from [foreign word].
And it's one of the many
portraits attributed
to the famous Mexican
photographer, Agustine Casasola,
throughout the maelstrom
of the revolution.
Not surprisingly, this portrait
was showcased on the flyers
for an exhibit titled, "The
African Presence in Mexico:
From Yanga to the Present."
Which opened at the Mexican Fine
Arts Museum in Chicago and traveled
to San Antonia, Los Angeles,
Oakland, Washington DC,
among other places,
between 2006 and 2011.
Taken against an improvised rustic
white background, the first thing
that arrests the viewer's eye,
as with many portraits,
is the subject's gaze.
This sitter is strong
and self-conscious.
You'll notice her chin is lifted
with her head pointing slightly
to the left, yet her gaze
looks straightforward.
Piercing the congealing
materiality of the photograph.
Perhaps, looking towards
where the photographer,
supposedly Casasola,
may have been standing.
Her gaze is imposing, and yet
the language of her body is
as impressive as her gaze.
Nonetheless, the comfortable
positioning
of her body contradicts
the threat hinted
at by the lower hand's proximity
to the gun that's holstered
in her pants pocket.
Oh, excuse me, revealing
the multiple codes signified
by the term soldadera, which in
traditional parlance precludes
military agency, but
often led directly to it,
to call her a soldadera and
not a soldier, a soldada,
deflects the military nature
of her position, and thus,
she's technically demoted.
So often in the work studied in this
book, soldadera, as a word choice,
which comes from the word soldada,
which actually means soldiers pay,
not females, soldiers pay,
what they're paid with.
Is exchanged for another more
dignified one, or in contrast,
soldadera is often used an insult.
This portrait is staged, but does
not follow the tradition typical
of military heraldry,
such as [foreign word],
the three-quarter positioning
of the head.
But, the metals displayed on her
chest, and the strategic position
of the gun, indicate that she
was a recognized military officer
within the revolution army,
and not simply a wife,
laundress, cook, or prostitute.
Certainly, what's intriguing
about this portrait
for the spectator is the fact
that she is both a soldadera
and a soldier; male and female,
decorative but practical.
And as a [foreign word]
black and white.
When compared to the gallery
of photographic images
that have been showcased
of male soldiers during the
revolution, they're rarely Mexican.
She is quite comfortable in the
traditional male realm of war,
yet is not quite ready to give
up that [foreign word]
of feminine aesthetic.
The ribbon adjoining her [foreign
word] and her earrings that are long
and dangling create a
striking counterpoint
to the gun she has not
removed from her pant pocket.
Or maybe that is the point.
Perhaps the viewer's
being instructed not
to conflate the vestiges of
female attire with weakness.
This woman seems to body the
contradictions of the war
and the term soldadera in addition
to the post-revolutionary
ideal of [foreign word].
Considering how Mexican
blackness is figured
into the marginalized experience of
the soldadera, add one more layer
to the soldadera's already
overblown and yet simplified legacy.
The portrait of this real
woman now tenuously identified
as Coronela Caremn Robles, from
[foreign word], from [foreign word]
in 1914 has traveled the visual
imagery of Afro Mexican scholars.
But has only recently, and I mean
recently, recuperated a proper name.
Alongside this excavated new
identity are only brief lines
fragmentary and conclusive
and sometimes contradictory.
Just last week I had
an anthropologist
who saw the cover my book say,
do you know for sure
that that's who that is?
And I said, no, but that's
who they think the is.
Inconclusive and contradictory
to fill in the gaps of her story.
This portrait defies
a static iconicity
that congeals and decontextualizes.
And instead, points to another more
powerful knowledge, [foreign word],
that has led to multiple
identifications
and a con commitment slippery truth.
Women were in the background,
but also took fierce
and strategic military rules.
This image is testament to this
woman's misunderstood history,
multiple names and elided
blackness and the fraught nature
of Mexican womanhood in general.
This nobody, like all the
other nobodies I discuss
in my book is still looking at us
and is still claiming her place
in the making of one of the most
important social revolutions
of the 20th century.
So, the first part of the book
"Entre Adelitas y Cucarachas:
The Soldadera as Trope
in the Mexican Revolution explores
the movement of the soldaderas
and their peripatetic migrations
outside of the domestic domain
and into the public sphere, creating
what I call a mobile habitus,
or as James Clifford has
theorized, a dwelling in travel.
Soldaderas were crucial to
military success in Mexico.
And regardless of whose side they
were on or what role they adopted,
I contend that the term soldadera
etymologically ambiguous,
becomes a word to describe
what was socially unacceptable.
It's a way to debase the real worth
of the militarily active
female participant of war,
and a way to describe women
living outside the confines
of traditional home.
As soldaderas, they cannot
expect any remuneration
or even recognition.
By breaking, from what Diana Taylor
calls from traditional notions
of female behavior, they
created what Diana Taylor calls a
performative scenario on top of
the train, around the campfire,
straggling behind the men.
This scenario, which is repeatable
prosaic, yet multivalent,
would brand their place
in the imaginary
of Mexicans for generations to come.
The revolutionary practices
and tactics
and divergent occupations
of place and space.
So, the second chapter explores
the representation of these women
in literary, visual
or cultural production
by impacting the prevailing
tropes that originate
in the [foreign word] the popular
ballads called "La Adelita"
and "La Cucaracha" and I'm just
curious if you guys have heard,
we've all heard "La
Cucaracha," sure?
"La Adelita" is similar,
there have been even samba,
rockabilly renditions
of "La Adelita," so,
it's a very important
rhythm that operates
in international circuits of music.
So, this chapter considers how
the overwhelming visibility
and shocking presence of the
soldadera forced popular balladeers
to change the conventions
naturalize by narrative balladry.
So, these [foreign word] are
not only recognized nationally
but are internationally
emblems of Mexican folk music.
And they operate as unofficial
anthems of the revolution.
And come to represent the whole
of female participation
in the revolution.
But what's ironic of course is
as ballads, as popular ballads
by folklorists, they were
not considered real examples
of [foreign word], in part because
of their of the rhythm and the lack
of a narrative story that there
were never real stories told
about female soldiers, just sort
of abstracted ideals of womanhood.
So, in chapter 3 of the first half
of the book I discuss
more ambivalent,
even subversive soldadera
figures that twist the rigidity
of "La Cucaracha" who's the whore,
and "La Adelita" sort of the Barbie,
the model, the sweetheart.
That twists those stereotypes
into unheard-of forms
that will constitute
new, albeit ephemeral,
practices of Mexican womanhood.
In the second part of the
book, so here we see examples
of "La Adelita and "La Cucaracha."
So, there's three popular
ballads there, excuse me.
So, the second part of the book,
"The Blacks in the Closet,"
unearths the legacy of
the African presence
in the Mexican cultural imaginary by
focusing on the figure of the mulata
and Mexican music in the
form of [foreign word]
and the provenance
of [foreign word].
The mulata like the soldadera,
lacks a proper name
and a place in society.
Identified only through
the sexual congress
of an anonymous black slave woman
and usually a Spanish father.
But unlike the muddled masses that
define the image of the soldadera,
mulatas marked their presence
through their emergence
of singular exceptional figures
that are easily brushed aside
by the populous as
curious anomalies.
So, the fourth chapter critically
compares the coastal legend
of the mulata, the [foreign word]
with a real inquisition case that's
housed in the National Archives
in Mexico City, of a runaway slave
named Antonia Desorta [assumed
spelling] from Northern Mexico.
And I observe how this
colonial legend of the mulata,
the [foreign word], which
was eventually turned
into a one-act opera, reflects a
whole mythology regarding black
women in Mexico.
They associate it with witch
craft, magic, unknown origins,
or as a topicalized elsewhere
that infected the local populous
with its hypersexualized
presence and then disappeared.
So, these disappearing
acts will mark the legacy
of all blacks in Mexico.
There are glimmers, hints,
traces, and insinuations.
But never claims about
their contributions
to Mexican history and culture.
So, this chapter, in short, examines
how blacks were part-in-parcel
of the nascent colonial regime and
culture, but were overrepresented
in the Inquisition archives and in
the juridical language of heresy,
witchcraft, and sexual dereliction.
So, I follow-up my study
of the colonial period
by examining the figure of the
mulata in Mexican films produced
at the height of the
Mexican golden era cinema.
And how they make an incipient
attempt to contend with the problem
of racism against Blacks in
Mexico through the tropes
of Manny's tragic mulatas
imported from the US
by representing blackness as
exceptional, or displacing it
onto the Caribbean, or abstracting
the positions of blacks into Mexico,
in Mexico into a universal
dilemma of racism as a part
of the legacy of slavery.
These films reproduce,
I argue the very racism
that the attempt to rectify.
The second part of
the book concludes
by discussing the audio tropic
and sonic landscape of Mexico
that is a product of the
Afro [foreign word] culture
of the Gold Coast.
I contend that blackness
inserts itself into the fabric
of the national narrative
through its most popular songs,
[foreign word] and "La Bamba".
We've all heard "La Bamba," no?
So, such songs, and in particular
"La Bamba" are startling examples
of how Mexico's nobodies are
the subjects and originators
of a musical tradition that would
come to constitute the culture
of a globalized Mexicanness.
This chapter further discusses
the impact of Cuban music
on Mexican cultural production
and identity by focusing
on the exceptional figure,
Antonia Lanegra [assumed spelling],
who is the matriarchal mulata who
was a national icon and performer
of [foreign word], the favorite
music of the dance halls
and brothels, and the Cuban
song from the Gulf Coast
of Mexico, Veracruz, in particular.
And it discusses how she
paradoxically constitutes the
quintessence of Mexicanness
through her status
as the model [foreign word],
despite her claim to blackness.
So, she's as Mexican as they
come, despite being black.
So, what do I mean by nobodies.
What does it allow me to do?
And I just want you to notice
that in the image there,
that's Celia Cruz.
So, there was a lot of interaction
between Caribbean and Cuba
in particular in Veracruz.
And so there's this way in
which blackness is displaced
onto Caribbeanness, but
in particular Cubanness.
So, what do I mean by nobodies,
and what does it allow me to do?
So, what this book seeks to discover
then, is the way this gendered
and rationalized construct
is belied,
undone through the very art
forms that perform this gendering
and racializing, and how these
pre-existing tropes are intertwined,
reproduced, and yet
contain gaping fault lines.
While womanhood and race
are invariably defined
in concrete terms, the tremors
that unsettle these constructs
are manifested by the fascination
with which both elites
and peasants beheld
and represented these
extraordinary people.
Black, mulatto, white,
mestizo, and indigenous women.
The cultural text examined
in this book ranging
from as I mentioned [foreign word]
popular ballads, films to opera,
witness the complex ways in which
traditional womanhood is defined
by masculinists gestures and
disruptive by rationalizing ones.
Indeed, the anxieties regarding
a hegemonic notion of race
and gender are brought to task
with the figure of [foreign word].
Her simultaneous masculine
and maternal heroism was an
embarrassment to military officials.
While the mulata triangulates
native blackness
with a foreign intrusion
and exotic sexuality.
Providing a way to negotiate
and explain unraveling sexual
[inaudible] in the countryside
and the corruption
of while male desire.
I argue that the figures
who populate the literary,
visual and musical
imaginary constitute much more
than base entertainment for
the masses or curious motif
and cultural production
by patronizing elites.
I argue that they reflect an almost
latent communal will to narrate
that which the official
history often ignores.
In the aesthetic, I claim
resides something more
than artifice possibility.
So, I propose nobodies
as an alternative
to understanding this fundamental
historical marginalization.
And it's over representation
in the arts.
As I've claimed, neither gender nor
race's critical categories can be
engaged independently.
Mexican nationalist discourse
and art, grapple specifically
with the tangled strands of both.
In contrast to this nominal
abstraction, the body
and nobody directly
points to the very real
and concrete place they
have in the background.
The spaces they occupy, the
contributions they make,
and the violence inflicted
upon the flesh.
Their nobody-ness is clearly
a product of their othering,
but also the practical and
strategic disappearing of them
by Mexican natural discourse.
Through the denial of a proper
name, cucaracha, adelita,
as well as the regulation
of their bodies.
This disappearing, however,
happened in different ways.
On the one hand, the
overrepresentation of the soldadero
in the crafting of a
post-revolutionary identity,
blinds the spectator or
reader through excess.
While on the other, the
absolute elision of blacks
from the Mexican historical
consciousness,
makes the striking figure of
the mulata exotic and foreign.
So, the promulgation of a
vacuous revolutionary rhetoric
that serves only the
authoritarian elites in the name
of murdered peasant icons
such as Poncho Villa,
and Emiliano Zapata featured
in this very famous image,
"Villa en la silla presidencial"
in the presidential seat,
or local movements celebrated on
the world stage, that have not,
in the case [foreign word], put
[foreign word], indigenous law
into place nor in the case
of [foreign word] today,
brought justice to the families
of the 43 disappeared
students a few years ago,
or even allowed Afro Mexicans to be
recognized as viable communities,
is testament to the reality that
Mexico is now more than ever,
an authoritarian state and that
the road towards democracy is
still long.
However, as argued
by Gareth Williams
and myself art registers
the profound necessary
and inevitable moments that allow
us to think and be otherwise.
The majestic effect
of this one portrait,
the once nameless Afro Mexican
soldadera staring intently
so that I was staring intently
into the camera with her gun
in her pocket, her military
pins, her [foreign word] hat
and dangling earrings defies the
static, post-revolutionary narrative
of abnegated womanhood and
melancholic [foreign word].
This woman alone through the
multiple ambivalences communicated
in the portrait, and its
contradictory captions.
In all versions that I read,
there were probably at least four
or five different captions
of who this person was.
Speaks of all the different
ways of being
and becoming a post-revolutionary
woman in Mexico.
The [foreign word], the popular
ballad bears witness to this.
Heralding war heroes
and manly valor,
it also did not ignore its women, if
only to present them as cockroaches
or Barbies; cucaracha and adelitas.
So, this permits the disfiguring
nature of cultural production
to simultaneously reveal other
possibilities beyond degenerate
cucarachas or beguiling adelitas.
To imagine the real people
who flitted in the background
as playing an integral role
in what is today Mexican
culture, history and politics.
So, before I conclude, I just
wanted to mention that the image
in the middle is, we've
just recently discovered,
the same [foreign word]
that's been on the cover,
is on the cover of my book.
It's not positively
identified, but Mexican scholar,
John Raz [assumed spelling]
has been able to make a link
between this image, who was also
in the archive identified
as a soldadera.
It's clear she's not a soldadera,
she's in the middle, right?
But it was identified as soldadera.
Now, she's identified as
Coronela Caremn Robles.
As I was finishing the book,
I still had to figure out.
I went through all the
different copies, and I realized
that this was the same person.
So, I'd like to conclude
with a few words
from my conclusion to be otherwise.
Okay. From May until August
2015, the Vincent Price Museum
in east Los Angeles hosted a suburb
exhibition titled "Soldadera"
By internationally
renowned performance
and video artist Nao Bustamante.
The multimedia exhibition imagined
through what the Chicana artist
calls a speculative reenactment.
The soldadera's participation
in the Mexican revolution.
Thoroughly mesmerizing,
haunting and dreamlike.
At the same time, it's
tactile, concrete and physical.
The exhibition features several
pieces that mix archival footage
and photography, such as the
images I just showed you,
with Bustamante's revisionary
and majestic work
and material craft
blurring the boundaries
between archive and invention.
And rending at the same time,
it weaves these women's stories
tightly together through the symbol
of a yellow, bullet-hugging Kevlar
[inaudible] dress, that's featured
in the middle of the image.
Filling the exhibition hall,
the cinematic installation
was a five-minute loop.
You see that in the far left
corner, was a cinematic loop;
five-minute loop of a mostly black
and white film projected
onto a 16 x 9 screen.
The video transposed reenactments
of soldaderas wearing
Bustamante's yellow Kevlar dresses,
onto archival footage, in order to
create what Bustamante's rendition
of the unfinished chapter dedicated
to the Soldadera from the film
"Que Viva Mexico" by the Russian
filmmaker, Sergei Eisentein.
Unfortunately, he was unable to
complete it because the project ran
out of money, and he was forced
to leave Mexico before production
on this segment could begin.
So, the soldadera's important role
in the revolution was
first visually imagined
by an avant-garde Russian filmmaker,
only to be completed 86 years later
by Chicana performance artists
from the San Joaquin Valley.
Both outsiders.
At the center of the room
in this exhibit was a series
of yellow dresses, bulky and
perceived thoroughly unfit
for the battleground of war.
The dresses, titled "[Foreign
Word] Kevlar" 2945 are crafted
as bulletproof gowns that would
withstand the piercing gunshots
of the Winchester 3030
rifle, the preferred weapon
of the revolutionary insurgents.
Kevlar design by a female chemist,
is a synthetic material woven
so tightly that it is five
times stronger than steel.
However, after a single
penetration, it begins to unravel.
Body Armor the soldaderas never had,
if only the real [inaudible] could
have been lined with this stuff.
It is a speculative
tribute to the thousands
of nameless denigrated women who
were killed on the battlefield,
raped, or maimed and
left and recognized.
In the words of Hannah Manchel
[assumed spelling], and I quote,
"Now Bustamante's Kevlar
dresses are, in a way,
garments protected by unraveling.
The dresses perform a
kind of vulnerability
about thinness and thickness.
A kind of vulnerability that cannot
go to pieces, when hit by a bullet
or when cut by an artist's
scissors, the fabric was thin,
unravels to protect
the body inside."
The display includes
several of the dresses,
but only one lives in a glass box.
The one we see here.
A sleeping beauty,
pierced with the slugs
of an original Winchester 3030.
The remaining dresses will
also eventually be fired on
and in this way, it is an ongoing
performance that will continue
to record and violate the
imagined and invented bodies
of these invisible women.
Phantasmagoric violence
that continues to pierce,
that withstands time and it's
punctuating deformations, ephemeral
and yet ineluctably felt.
Hidden at the back of the exhibition
hall is an understated piece called
the "Chac Mool."
Perhaps the most complex component
of the entire "Soldadera"
exhibition.
It is a remake of a
Mesoamerican statute
that features a reclining figure
whose head faces forward 90 degrees
and whose abdomen usually houses
a bowl for sacrificial items.
And is often associated with Tlaloc,
the Aztec God of rain and fertility.
An almost incredible reenactment
to see it, the spectator's forced
to pierce through the anti-view
finder we saw in the previous image,
whose circular form remind us
of Tlaloc's prominent eyes.
In order to observe a small
screen that loops 12 minutes
of Becerra Lumbreras on her bed,
the woman featured on the screen,
the oldest person alive at the time.
Although Guinness refuses
to put her in the record
because she lost her birth
certificate 40 years prior.
And the last surviving soldadera
of the Mexican Revolution.
At 127 years of age, she
reclined on her perch of pillows
on a makeshift bed, a
living [foreign word],
who a month after her encounter with
Bustamante was to leave the earth,
having outlived all of her children
and many of her grandchildren.
She finally told her story
through the persistent tapping
of an unknown rhythm
in the video loop.
Her communicatory gesture revealing
her engagement with the revolution
for the first time in public,
and for the last time in private,
the to team that Bustamante
gathered in their quest
to meet the last living Soldadera.
I want to explain that.
She couldn't speak anymore, so
she just tapped in the video loop.
It took over 100 years, she waited
patiently, but her body spoke.
And she was heard.
A Moises Medina who accompanied
Bustamante's crew attest that,
and I quote, "Very little was
vocalized, but much was said."
Becerra Lumbreras was
one of the few who fought
for her communal land grant, and
withstood the chiding of others,
as she demanded her revolutionary
pension and I quote, "Vocally,
insisting that she had bled,
fought, and mothered children
of the of the revolution."
The cleverness of this installation
is the paradoxical analogy
that Bustamante draws between
Lumbreras and the [foreign word].
A Mesoamerican statute whose
role is not understood.
Who lays in an almost semi-supine
position, except that it rest
on its forearms, reclined,
vulnerable, and yet active.
Located outside of the sacred
temples, but not part of them.
Spread throughout the diverse
indigenous world across time
and space associated with fertility,
but upon whose belly rested the ball
for the sacrificial victims,
or reverential items,
no one knows for sure.
An icon that was misnamed by
the person who discovered it.
Not unlike the soldadera,
the name stuck.
Jennifer Doyle, the curator
of the exhibition explains
the work in a quote.
"Our intention as artist and
curator is to invite the viewer
of the exhibition to consider the
possibilities of the speculative,
even utopian thinking as not a
retreat from the here and now.
But as a deep engagement of
how we might imagine the here
and now, differently."
The women in my book
may have frayed stories,
occupy semi-supine
positions, hover in the shadows
between maternal instinct and macho
valor, blackness and whiteness,
respectability and audacity.
But like Becerra Lumbreras
have outlived
and questioned their very objection
in the art that they've inspired
and the stories that are told
or tapped with their fingers,
and in the case of
Becerra Lumbraras,
in the very life she refused to
leave behind as super centenarian.
This Pueblo is not monolithic.
Indeed, it's composed of all
different kinds of people, lifeways,
histories, bodies,
and [foreign word].
The practice of daily life, the
organic mixture of quotidian ritual,
and the praxis of culture, even in
the midst of its creation points
to the constant revolutions
that happen
when diverse people come together
in the wake of violent events.
Whether these events are slavery,
invasions, revolts against tyranny,
spiritual violence, the unjust
appropriation of ancestral land,
or gender aggression the
practice of living these events,
of living rupture and continuity
generates a sense of pueblo,
even when the pueblo itself
is far from homogeneous.
Art and popular culture
can intervene,
although not always evenly,
when history leaves off.
At least this has been the
case with Mexico's nobody's.
Thank you so much for listening.
[ Applause ]
I'm happy to entertain
any questions.
And again, thank you all for being
here, this is the thrill of my life.
Ten years of work, yes?
May I ask you to identify yourself,
so I know who I'm talking to.
>> Dene Barr:
>> Dene Barr [assumed spelling].
I'm a researcher in the
Hispanic Division here
at the Library of Congress.
I study filmmaking, first of all, at
University of Maryland College Park.
Eisentein, when I hear Eisentein, I
need to know the name of that film,
I'd like to see that film.
>> Christina Arce:
"Que Viva Mexico."
It is one of the first films made
about the Mexican revolution.
He had designed it with a
segment of the soldadera in mind.
But he got ran out of Mexico
because what he was doing.
It's sort of like; oh, I'm sorry.
It's very sort of revolutionary
documentary form.
And so, this is one of
the most famous pieces.
And of course, you know, Mexicans
look at it as Mexican art,
but it was made by a
Russian filmmaker in Russian.
So, yeah, it's available on YouTube.
You can see it on YouTube
but the quality's not good.
And because of the visual
imagery and the different; yes?
May I know who you are?
>> Eve Ferguson: My name is Eve
Ferguson [assumed spelling],
I work in the African Section
at the Middle Eastern
division her at the library.
And so, my question is,
like contemporary artists,
like Lila Downs is now shining
a light on Afro Mexican music.
Is there a greater acceptance in
Mexican society, the contributions
of Afro Mexicans now
than previously.
>> Christina Arce: That
is a spectacular question.
And there's a greater awareness,
I don't know if there's
a greater acceptance.
They're still not recognized.
There was; among scholars there is.
There's a whole field
of Afro Mexican studies.
And there's Mexican scholars and
there are North American scholars
who have sort of in
tandem engaged in both.
Sometimes at odds with each other.
But, yes. I mean there's definitely
a much broader recognition.
Oh, yes, yes, we did have some
blacks but they were, you know,
at the beginning of
the colonial period.
So, there's a way in which it's
sort of you know it was so long ago.
And after [foreign word],
there's this lack of recognition
for individual populations
and communities
that in fact still have
vibrant Afro Mexican cultures,
for example, in the costas.
There's a way in which they
relegate it to coastal culture,
but they were part of the
intricate part of the construction
of Mexican culture
throughout the colonial period,
because they weren't just
relegated to the coast,
they were in fact in
the mining centers.
That's where the slaves were,
they worked in the mines.
And so, the particular case that
I look at is not the gulf coast
of Veracruz, where there
is a general acceptance
of blackness there, or even the
Pacific coast where there were oh,
yeah, you know Cimarron
Maroon colonies.
No, they more than [inaudible]
colonies, they were part
of the mining communities
and so the [foreign word],
or the women who made the chocolate
were almost always Afro Mexican.
There was a link between the two.
So, the general population is mixed
in terms of how they accept it.
Even the scholars will say that
chicanos and chicanas in particular
over determined the
blackness of Mexican culture.
Well you know, they exaggerate it.
Still to this day.
I mean, I go; I've been to
two conferences last year,
where I presented some material,
and as chicana, they looked at me
like well, you know, you guys
are over exaggerating it.
That's part of the North American
Academy, and sort of the discourse
of identity politic that's
permeated Afro diasporic studies.
So, it's mixed.
Yes?
>> John Taupping: Yeah, my name is
John Taupping [assumed spelling],
I'm a cataloger here at the library.
Is there a distinction
in Mexican Spanish
between la negra and la mulata?
There was that famous
singer named la Negra,
but I think normally you
were, typically you referred
to Afro Mexican women as mulata,
is there a distinction
between the two terms?
>> Christina Arce: No,
that's a great question.
Because it has to do
with the naming.
So, it was very popular among
Caribbean musicians in particular
to be identified through that
sort of nominal blackness.
So, for example, her
nephew took on el negro too,
[foreign word], or
something like that.
And so, that's a way to over
accentuate the blackness,
which then appealed to the sort
of tropicalizing discourse of oh,
you know she is la negra,
when in fact she's a mulata.
So, yeah, there is.
That's the etymological difference.
I mean, mulata is part
of the racial taxonomies
that were part of the
colonial period.
I mean I'm not sure
everyone knows the paintings,
the [foreign word] paintings
throughout the colonial period.
Are we familiar with those?
Where all the different racial
taxonomies were epitomized
through these portraiture,
which then became.
You know, many of those, there was
only five, six, maybe half a dozen
that were regularly used, mulata
being one of the principal ones.
But in terms of performativity
to take on el negro
or la negra was very common,
when in fact they were mulatos.
It's also a term of endearment,
in the Caribbean [speaking
in foreign language], you know,
so it's a term of endearment,
in addition to being
a derogatory term,
usually in the diminutive
[speaking in foreign language].
But it depends, it really
depends on the context.
In Brazil, it's the same.
It's often used as a
term of endearment.
>> George Rice: Hi, my name is
George Rice, nice to meet you.
So, I was born in Mexico
City and I just want
to verify what my grandfather,
you know,
he's been telling me this for years.
So, one of the questions was why we
really never talk about black people
in Mexico, he says basically
one of the reasons is
that you know, they were free.
They were not slaves in Mexico.
And you know there was
never really an issue.
So, I just want to verify that.
And I had a question
on your picture,
you mentioned that she had a gun.
You know, Mexican culture
tends to be [foreign word],
so I wonder if that comes
from a feminist movement
where women were allowed
to carry arms.
Because I know for a
fact in other cultures,
women were you know,
they're homemakers.
They sit at home, take
care of the kids.
So, I just found that
piece fascinating.
>> Christina Arce: It is.
It's incredible.
There's actually a
transgender [foreign word],
who's also names [foreign
word], who only shows to where,
she immediately transferred
into male garb.
Oftentimes when they were colonels,
or when they h ad a military rank
that was beyond just the common
soldier, they would sort of perform
that authority through
dress, through the vestments.
But you'll notice what's
interesting about that is
that she still wears the earrings.
There's this way in which she's
still not abandoning her femaleness,
you know her femininity
in terms of the garb.
So, she's using both.
So, that sort of gesture
is really interesting.
You know, so but definitely,
during the revolution many
soldaderas took up arms.
Maybe they performed
traditional female roles
by bringing the domesticity of
the home onto the battlefield.
I mean that in itself was
incredibly radicalizing to see women
and children out on the
battlefield hanging clothes,
carrying their [foreign
word], making beans.
But then at the same time when their
soldier fell, they would often pick
up the rifle and continue
fighting for them,
or they were looked to as leaders.
I mean there's all
kinds, there's all;
one of the most important
novels written by a Mexican,
it's a testimonial novel by Elana
Pontitosca [assumed spelling] was
precisely the interview of a
soldadera who followed her father
and then and then her
husband into the war.
And then when both of them fell,
the soldiers look to her to lead.
So, there's this way in which,
there's a fluidity in gender roles
that wartime, exigencies
of wartime will permit.
But what happens after the war?
They decided that soldaderas
were unacceptable.
They made them wives.
And that made it very difficult
for them to seek their pensions
as revolutionary participants.
That's what makes the situation
of [foreign word] so important is
that she actually demanded it,
as a veteran of the
revolution, as a soldadera.
No? So, they took all
kinds of different roles.
They were often spies,
smugglers and strategists.
So, they took on different roles.
And then some were just simply
cooks, and they were able
to market themselves as through
their culinary expertise,
their ability to make
a lot out of nothing.
Because they handle the
soldada, the soldier's money,
and were able to purchase
provisions.
Remember there was no
commissary or even infirmary.
So, that's what the
roles of soldaderas did.
With regards to the first
comment on blacks in Mexico.
Yes, Mexico was I think the
second country to abolish slavery.
The second president of the
Mexican Republic after independence
from Spain was an Afro Mexican.
I mean people don't know that.
They get whitened later on.
One of the primary revolutionary
leaders was [foreign name]
and he was also not
from [foreign word].
And during the colony period, I
think what your father was eluding
to was there was a very
prominent working class.
Freed, black class.
Why? Because slavery lasted
a generation or two at most.
There was certainly the
chattel plantation model,
which is what we think of
when we think of slavery,
these big cotton plantations.
In Mexico it would've been sugar,
tobacco, [foreign word], and mining,
but they were also
petaled off slavery,
a slave could often acquire the
official, you know, of his master
and the master often freed
him in his own lifetime.
And the children were
often godchildren.
So, there's this patronage,
of course,
but they were often
freed in their lifetime.
So, it would last a
generation or two at most.
And there was an urban class,
it was an urban phenomenon.
Mexico City had more blacks than
it did Spaniards at one point.
In part because of slavery.
But it's this particularized,
sort of localized slavery;
fruit sellers, the shoemaker.
I mean so they turned
into a vibrant class
that then became Hispanicized
really early on.
And so, they mixed
in really early on.
So, there's an insistence
on phenotype.
They said, well we don't
really have what looks
like Brazil or Cuba here in Mexico.
Thus, we don't really have an
important black population.
But it mixed in really early on.
And so, the slave trade
was abrogated very early
on in Mexico as well.
And they had rights
because of Canon Law.
Because of the pope.
So, they were able
to appeal the rights.
I'm not saying that slavery
wasn't horrible in Mexico.
But what I am saying is that they
had a little more liberty to appeal
through the church, through the
mechanisms of the church to appeal
to have regular families and to get
Sundays off and stay in the cities.
Or, they mixed in with indigenous
populations, which is understudied.
In part because there was,
in colonial Mexico [speaking
in foreign language].
Many times blacks would escape
to the indigenous communities.
And then they were
no longer accounted.
And the last part about that is that
blacks also, there was no census.
Because of that sort of viciousness
with regards to the caste system.
The [foreign word], the
second president abrogated,
he also eliminated the caste system,
so that they would all be Mexicans,
but then unfortunately eliminated
the record of blacks in Mexico.
So thus, the invisibility
for 200 years until now.
Yes. What's your name?
>> Desiree.
Hi. Thank you so much
for this [inaudible].
Can you give us a sense of what
the relationship was between middle
and upper class women who
kind of busied themselves
with like legal equity and feminism,
feminist work, and the soldadera.
>> Christina Arce: Oh, during
the revolutionary period?
Oh, that's a great question.
Because there's a lot; not
a lot, but more written
on precisely the upper class women
who; I mean the first battle cry
of the Mexican revolution, which
preceded the Cuban Revolution,
preceded the Russian Revolution,
was actually at an upper-class
woman's house [foreign word]
in northern Mexico.
So, they had a real important role,
in part because they were completely
on the outside of Mexican society.
So, because of the dictatorship
of the paternalistic
patriarchal society.
So, women in particular
upper-class women; so,
there has been some scholarship,
particularly, Mexican scholars
and North American scholars have
focused a lot on that relationship.
Also, soldaderas were not looked
upon, they sort of like presented
as this degenerate femininity.
So, there was certainly
class tensions.
One of the most important; so,
they would not have taken nicely
to being called soldaderas.
You know, because it was sort of
a pejorative way to call some sort
of trashy women who
followed the troops right.
It was almost like calling
them a prostitute, right?
Whereas adelita acquired this
short of sweetheart intonation.
So, definitely, I mean, but one
of the most important figures
[foreign name] who wrote a book
that was not published
in her lifetime.
She went broke supporting
the revolution,
she founded the White
Cross in Mexico.
And was one of the primary
advisors to the [foreign word]
who became president
afterwards regime.
She was completely
unrecognized up until 20 years ago
when [foreign name] recovered her
book that was rejected over 20 times
by different editorials in
Mexico and in the United States.
She wrote her book in
Spanish and English.
And is called [foreign
word], the rebel.
And so, certainly she talks about,
she oftentimes will be disinclined
to call the female
companion soldaderas.
She'll call them, you know,
the nurse, or something else.
[Foreign name], did the same.
She wrote a beautiful set of short
stories on the Mexican Revolution
and she also, in a such a subsequent
revision took the word soldadera out
and replace it with
woman or muchacha, no?
Because I mean in a way to
not reduce into that level.
So, they were very much,
there's a distinction
between those class levels,
yet women of upper-classes
joined the revolutionary forces,
were often strategists.
[Foreign name] had a
female strategist and orator
that wrote five books on
the Mexican Revolution.
None of that is recognized.
Thank you so much for
coming this has been
such an honor for me to be here.
Thank you, Georgette [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.